economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela
comenzamos hablando del fondo monetario
internacional que comenzará a
desembolsar recursos a los países pobres
y en desarrollo que tal santiago pues lo
va a hacer a través de los denominados
derechos especiales de giro ese es un
activo de reserva internacional que se
puede convertir en cinco monedas dólares
estadounidenses euros yenes libras
esterlinas y yuanes cuando un país
recibe estos derechos puede mantenerlos
como parte de sus reservas en moneda
extranjera o cambiarlos por la moneda de
otros miembros del fondo monetario
internacionales o para ayudar a
fortalecer sus monedas pero para países
pobres vienen libres de condiciones o
intereses a diferencia de un préstamo
tradicional en esta que es la inyección
más grande de la historia del fm y se
asignaron 650 mil millones de dólares
unos 275.000 millones se destinarán a
países emergentes y en desarrollo y
otros 21 mil millones de dólares a
países de bajos ingresos entre los
beneficiados en la región está por
ejemplo argentina va a recibir alrededor
de 4.400 millones y méjico que tendrá
más de 12.000 millones hablemos de
américa latina' la economía de perú
creció más del 40% en el segundo
trimestre de este año si santiago pues
el producto interno bruto avanzó un 41,9
por ciento para ser exactos entre abril
y junio si se compara con el mismo
período del año pasado cuando se había
contraído un 30,2 por ciento en el peor
momento de la pandemia por eso es que es
un efecto rebote del que siempre
hablamos sin embargo todavía está medio
punto porcentual por debajo de lo que se
registraba en el segundo trimestre de
2019 una buena noticia para una economía
que en todo 2020 se desplomó un 11 por
ciento interrumpiendo 22 años
consecutivos de crecimiento económico
pero la mala noticia es que en esta
nación suramericana hay dos problemas
macroeconómicos hoy en día la
devaluación de su moneda local que ha
perdido más del 13% este año frente al
dólar y la inflación los precios al
consumidor santiago acumularon en julio
una variación
anual del 38 % que es más de lo que
esperaba el gobierno dentro de sus
planes para este año seguimos en la
región daniel hablemos ahora del
salvador a ya están ultimando detalles
para que entre en funcionamiento el
bitcoin y el mundo entero está
observando porque es el primer país del
mundo en implementarlo a partir del 7 de
septiembre exactamente entra en vigencia
la ley que permitirá el uso de la cripto
moneda más grande del mundo como moneda
de curso legal y el presidente en el
ipvu que le reveló que el país va a
contar con una red de 200 cajeros en los
que los salvadoreños tendrán la
posibilidad de retirar dólares en
efectivo pero el mandatario ha sido
bastante criticado por haber introducido
este tipo de pago por eso puso un largo
mensaje en su cuenta personal de
facebook entre otras cosas asegura que
combi con los ciudadanos van a poder
abrir un pequeño negocio recibir dinero
de familiares o amigos así como remesas
y sin pagar un solo centavo de
comisiones justamente está quieto moneda
nació hace años con esa intención de que
se hicieran transacciones sin pasar por
el sistema financiero ni por la lupa de
las las económicas ya veremos cómo les
va danielle hablemos del líbano al
gobierno de ese país repartirá bonos en
efectivo a todos los ciudadanos pues el
parlamento de ese pequeño país de medio
oriente aprobó en marzo un préstamo de
246 millones de dólares del banco
mundial que iba a proporcionar
asistencia a más de 160 mil familias
pero la medida se retrasó por la
insistencia del gobierno en que iba a
entregar esas ayudas en libras libanesas
por eso ahora decidió pagarla en dólares
aunque no quedó claro cuánto les van a
dar el plan inicial del gobierno era
entregar a cada familia 800 mil libras
libanesas al mes por un año esto
equivale a un poco más de seis mil
libras el dólar calculado para este fin
aunque está dividida en el mercado
ilegal llega hasta las 20.000 libras 3
veces más esta decisión se produce justo
antes de que a finales del próximo mes
el gobierno ponga fin a los subsidios a
los combustibles una medida que causó
bastante malestar entre los ciudadanos
indicadores wall street se cerró con
ganancias y con recorte en su índice
nasdaq que agrupa a las empresas
tecnológicas gracias entre otros a la
aprobación completa de la vacuna the
fighter iv by on dec en américa latina
la bolsa mexicana logró un nuevo máximo
histórico en menos de una semana
es todo por el momento aquí en la
economía en france 24 gracias daniela
sigan con nuestra programación